hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully
you've all had a chance to see the first
episode of the flash I already did a
non-spoilery review so this video is
going to be a top 10 don't forget that
the first episode of arrow is tomorrow
night - it's gonna be amazing
I will be doing videos for all the DC TV
shows every week so be sure to subscribe
to get everything I'm probably gonna do
some random giveaways too so careful for
spoilers from the flash if you haven't
seen the episode yet I'll wait just a
sec okay everybody ready here we go top
10 moments number 10 John Wesley Shipp
the original flash is Barry's father
this is one of the best callbacks to the
old flash TV show from the 90s not to
make any puns but that didn't run for
very long that version of the character
left a pretty big mark and he was the
Barry Allen version just like this one
is his original co-star on that Amanda
pays has actually been cast on the new
flash TV show - she's going to be
playing the exact same character it'll
be dr. Tina McGee of STAR Labs it's just
really awesome of the producers to
include the classic cast in that big way
John Wesley ship's character is going to
be stuck in iron Heights for most of the
season but the good news is is that is
where they stick all the criminals
that's like the Arkham Asylum for the
flash number 9 the professor zoom T's
right off the bat in the beginning they
just come right out and say it you know
yes big yellow blur probably going to be
the big Bell in this season just for
reference during the tcas greg berlanti
and andrew kriesberg said that the
reverse-flash would start to manifest
early in the seasons so expect to see
more of him after the first couple of
episodes you know maybe like by episode
4 or 5 or 6 just in time to get ready
for the mid-season finale yes I do think
that Professor zoom will appear in the
mid-season finale it might not be the
professor zoom version of the character
it might be one of the other reverse
flashes I just feel like midseason
finales are bookmarked for big villain
reveals that's when they revealed Slade
is the big villain of arrow season 2 so
I am expecting zoom in that mid-season
finale
number 8 the superhero CSI aspect to the
show the flash is an origin story for a
whole lot of comic book characters not
just the flash himself so naturally it
lends itself to the process of discovery
and being that Barry Allen works at a
police station it's going to be
something of a superhero CSI show I
don't think they're going to get too
hardcore with
position like they do on CSI this is the
CW after all it's more about the
characters than about the powers but the
big teases of this map here on the
screen all these pockets of energy will
be creating new super villains and new
heroes they already have cast a ton of
comic-book characters and they've been
filming with them I'm gonna wait till a
lot of them pop up to talk about him
just because there are so many number 7
fairies mystery board tracking his
mother's murder this is going to be one
of the other big plots for season 1
solving the mystery of what really
happened the night his mother was
murdered during the same TCA panel I
just mentioned the producer said they
would be staying really faithful to the
general arc of flash rebirth
that's the comic that Geoff Johns used
to bring Barry Allen back from the dead
he'd been dead in the comics up to that
point everyone should totally read it
it's totally awesome and they're
probably going to be discounting it
they're probably giving big discounts on
it but the big murder mystery ties in
with the big villain plot and for those
that have read the comic just please use
spoiler tags when you're commenting
about it number 6 gorilla grodd teaser
there hasn't been any confirmation that
Grodd is going to be in season 1 greg
berlanti actually said he had to argue
with the network to keep that easter egg
in there they were just trying to have
some fun with the fans at the time but
they are structuring things so that it's
possible for them to do Grodd if they
want to at some point
nothing's off the table in terms of
Flash characters like that universe is
open to them they even said that they're
going to be doing Wally West at some
point not anytime soon
but eventually number 5 Ferris air I
know everyone totally wants to know when
Green Lantern is going to come on arrow
the flash if they do end up bringing him
to the TV show universe it would
probably be through arrow first like
they would bring Hal Jordan onto arrow
or it's possible they could bring Carol
Ferris onto the flash they have said
that they're open to Green Lantern
someday there's not really room for him
this season there's already like too
many big characters but there's nothing
stopping them from doing a cameo in a
future season I do kind of feel like
they would probably do Carol Ferris
first just because it'd be easier to
deal with that character like there'd be
less clearance required number 4 Caitlin
snows research and her fiance have both
been killed by the blast Caitlin snow
for anyone that doesn't know in the
comics is killer frost which is a
villain she was actually in the Suicide
Squad movie they released a little while
ago it's possible that on the show
danielle panabaker could have
hours and just not be telling anyone
about it supposedly she's going to be on
Team flash so she'll be one of the good
guys we'll probably have to wait till
that midseason finale to see where the
characters going but her fiancee that
supposedly died is Ronnie Raymond aka
firestorm from the comics he's being
played by Robbie Amell on the show we're
gonna meet him in like Episode three or
four I think it might be episode three
but he will become firestorm
Robbie Mel's been tweeting all kinds of
pictures from the set and it totally
looks amazing of all the big comic book
characters they're bringing on the show
this season the secondary characters I
say firestorm is the one I'm most
excited about number three weather
wizard is the first of many many roads
they've already cast a bunch of the
other rogues and they even just posted
the first official picture of Wentworth
Miller as Captain cold with his cold gun
like they literally just posted this
right before this episode of the flash
aired I'm hoping by the end of the
season they actually do team up and call
themselves the Rogues for those
wondering what happened to weather
wizard at the end of this episode
they're basically going to end up
throwing him in iron Heights like he'll
be thrown in prison feel free to make
any prison jokes you want because there
are a lot of Prison Break actors playing
rogues I'm totally not joking there are
a ton of Prison Break people and a ton
of Spartacus people coming on the show
it's gonna be a lot of fun
number two detective pretty boy has an
unusual name so they gave him the very
loaded name Edward Thawne obviously a
play on a o Barth on professor zoom it's
pretty clear he's normal in this episode
I don't think he has powers but it's
possible that they named him like
professor zoom but they'll give him the
storyline from hunter zolomon in the
comics Zola man works at the police
station and shares a lot of the
exhibited qualities of Rick cuz net the
actor in this episode there are a lot of
other directions that could go with it
but I just think that that's what's
going to happen the really interesting
thing is they did not let Rick cuz net
attend any of the press tour events like
whenever they took the actors to do
interviews and stuff they didn't take
him so I just feel like that means that
he's tied up with the big villain plot
and my number one moment of course huge
newspaper twist at the end
the Harrison wells future newspaper
could mean a lot of things he could be
professor zoom he could be another one
of the reverse flashes or he could be a
future version of Barry Allen the big
Easter Egg that everyone's been talking
about is the Queen industries waynetech
merger that's not intended to be
anything special
just like the gorilla grodd thing it's
just the writers we can get the fans and
this crisis thing isn't an Infinite
Crisis storyline teaser or anything like
that either
Harrison wells though is someone we
definitely need to keep our eyes on like
he is someone who definitely has ties to
the future let me know that what was
your favorite moment from the episode
and what did you think of this Stephen
Amell crossover just one of many many
future arrow crossovers coming
don't forget arrow season 3 starts
tomorrow I'll be posting my video for
that after the episode airs so be sure
to subscribe to get it
I'll try to get out a few more bonus
videos before then but I will be doing a
Q&A for both the arrow in the flash on
Thursday for those that are asking you
don't absolutely have to watch both the
arrow in the flash to understand each of
the shows but it will make it a lot more
fun if you watch both so I would
recommend it also I'll try to include
some of the comic books the weekly you
know arrow season 2.5 and flash season 0
comics in the videos that I do for both
of these shows so right now click here
for my review of the episode and click
here to start getting ready for arrow
season 3 thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you